this morning in our series note to self
a personal story that takes us behind
the culinary genius of the celebrated
Israeli American chef Michael Solomonov
he won his fifth James Beard Award in
May when his flagship restaurant Zahav
was can you move the camera in a little
closer I really can't see was named the
best restaurant in America this summer
he opened his six restaurant and will
open two more this fall all in
Philadelphia as a 41 year old Solomonov
enjoys a career high we asked him to
reflect on the struggles he fought and
the lessons he's still learning in a
note to his younger self Thank You
camera
mic you my friend will be experiencing
pain so agonizing that even if I tried I
could not fully explain
I wish this was not your fate but it is
and I'm sorry David Solomon off a staff
sergeant in the Israeli army killed by a
sniper yesterday on the Lebanon border
you will not be able to save your
younger brother David you cannot roll
back the clock you cannot protect him
and you cannot take that bullet for him
the last time you will remember seeing
him will be in mom's doorway you will
embrace him and tell him how proud you
are to be his brother and he will hear
you
while shrugging off the hug he'll
probably use that memory to torture
yourself for a while and it'll take a
while for you to accept this but what a
gift you had to be able to get to know
him and for him to get to know you
you're crying now while reading this
it's okay I'm crying too despite us
being ugly Criers and all you should let
yourself sob every now and again
followed by a few deep breaths
shema yisrael adonai elohenu adonai
echad perhaps saying the Shema which
ironically will be your mantra despite
loathing Hebrew school
you spend years trying to numb this pain
while simultaneously adding more you
will hurt yourself and the people that
you are closest to they use drugs and
alcohol that will work to destroy you
originally a way to deal with losing
David but the feeling of intense
emptiness and deep sorrow so powerful
knowing that he was killed when he was
just a child I promise you all of those
substances they won't fill that hole in
your heart
we'll fight addiction for five years but
one can argue you'll need to fight it
for your entire life
I want you to know and I need you to
know your friends and your family love
you respect you and care deeply for you
it is okay to ask for help
it is necessary
it's what we do and what we ask of our
loved ones in our darkest hours
you cannot do everything on your own
excuse the cooking analogy but nobody
likes a cook that Rex dinner service
because they refused to ask for help a
good cook knows when to ask for help
cooking will be your salvation you'll
share your brother's life and your
Israeli roots through your restaurants a
huff you will not be able to walk away
and when things get hard and I'm sorry
about this Mike but you'll have to
experience this pain clean and sober -
you'll have to feel all the feelings
emotional and physical and learn the
true meaning of life on life's terms the
hob became a destination restaurant the
Beard Award goes to Michael Solomonov
all you accomplished Mike solomonov has
hit the apex with Sahab all the success
and accolades raha was named the best
restaurant in America thank you
everybody that the supported us will be
possible because you got clean and
committed to staying clean
the sharp eye on our old friend guilt
that beast is just waiting for you to
end up in an emotion filled dark alley
somewhere and then
just breathe
[Music]
all that tripping guilt is just
self-indulgent it enables the most
destructive behavior which makes you
feel guilty more selfish encourages your
addictive behavior you can see where I'm
going with this perhaps just a spritz of
guilt on the neck and wrists and be done
with it
now listen very carefully actually
that's my advice just listen very
carefully shut your mouth and listen
[Music]
listen to the people who are looking out
for you and will be frightened and
scared of you hurting yourself listen to
your friends your co-workers especially
your business partner your best friend
listen to the guest that will come in to
Sahab and the team that you will be part
of don't stop being a student never
allow yourself to get cocky or
complacent complacency can lead to a
personal and professional death and it
may sound dramatic I know but trust me
it is true if you don't commit to
getting better every day you will get
worse and if you rest on your spiritual
laurels you will die
got it I love you Mike
[Music]
so many little so many little pearls
there shut your mouth and listen
sharp eye on our Oprah and gilt we all
know that person maybe Brits of guilt on
the wrists and neck it's okay to ask for
help in fact it's necessary I love the
next-to-last one if you don't commit to
getting better every day you will get
worse and I heard your voice on that
Anthony Mason which means when I did
when we did this as food good of course
it was being come on in America I forgot
myself for a second Saturday I thought
that was great and special mommy hook
shout out to Craig Shea who edited
beautiful here at Cleveland well done
yeah we like that bravo Bravo